regardez bien ce caillou c'est ce qu'on
appelle une bombe
pas de panique il s'agit d'un lambeaux
de lave qui s'est refroidie et
solidifier durant sa chute au moment
d'une éruption
je les ramasse et sur les pentes de
l'etna le volcan sicilien la lave est
projetée par les gaz contenus dans la
chambre magmatique qui en remontant se
détendent comme les bulles de champagne
et bouche la matière en fusion à
l'extérieur le trajet de cette borne a
été suffisamment long pour que la lave
très fluide au départ tourne sur
elle-même et prennent la forme d'une
goutte ce petit bourrelet témoigne du
mouvement j'adore cette roche vous
rendez compte
elle est restée confinée des milliards
d'années avant de mettre le nez dehors
allez à demain et surtout n'oubliez pas
nous sommes tous confinés mais en
restant bien si vous avez aimé cette
capsule 2d confiné n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleus gens réalisent
une nouvelle chaque jour alors pour ne
pas les rater abonnez-vous et activer la
cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain